[Music]
my name is iris West would you marry me
and I was supposed to marry the fastest
man alive
keep loving keep running for me I
promised him I run so that's what I've
been doing running
[Music]
how could you possibly be for it and
what do you want me to do curl up in a
ball and cry all day sometimes I feel
like if I believe that something hard
enough that'll make it real
I miss my friend Aires not coming back
you don't know that Barry told me to be
strong and being strong guy boy look at
that
expecting someone else
hey I don't understand this should have
worked
dead-bang fellas
you're up against them that hombre what
do you think you're going to do against
us with a sword
me the flash or as your city Paul how
kind of sort is that if we don't offer
up the flash people are going to die and
that's going to be on us I've made a few
slight modifications as Captain solo
would say iris you of all people how can
you not be in on this something
okay go
[Music]
Hevy Comic Con we continues everybody
the flash is back we finally got season
four footage let's break this down and
there's a new round of the flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video so we get to see Wally in the red
suit that's the big thing here obviously
we knew Barry was coming back but the
big question was Wally ever going to
step up we got some teases from behind
the scenes they filmed the first episode
they started filming the second Grant
Gustin showed up like hey you know I'm
back Barry's back but even though they
teased the rebirth like the idea that
episode one is titled flash reborn we
didn't know how much of the comic book
story they were going to do for that
because they've been a couple different
versions of rebirth malicious goes to
this shot by shot the biggest thing
being the big tease at the end were
they're like I got him I got him they're
back on the Feres airfield strip from
the pilot episode they're going all the
way back to the pilot you don't really
believe he can run that fast to you I
believe anything is possible and in a
few minutes
maybe you will too how's it fit
[Music]
solo snug and it looks like they've used
this avatar gun that they were going to
use to splice him across time to reverse
bring back Barry out of the speedforce
and that's part of the trick of it you
see the samurais actions that we've seen
from behind the scenes
bring me the flash or else so that's
probably the reason why they have Wally
put the red costume on so he is the
flash for that part of the episode until
Barry comes back but the funny thing
about this even though the tone is
really somber when they open up like
they've all been trying to deal with the
trauma of losing Barry what happened
last season she says she's been running
this whole time she's actually taking a
more active role in running things at
STAR Labs a more administrative role
because she's not a scientist but like
you see the surprise Caitlin snow she's
not killer frost but danielle panabaker
confirmed that you would see equal parts
killer frost and Caitlin snow so even
though in the trailer here she's got
Captain colds gun that's a bit of a wink
at the fact that she's still going to be
doing evil stuff and she has that choker
on she has a little bit more makeup so
it's almost like this version of Caitlyn
it's just going to be a lot more fun you
guys probably know by now that [ __ ] is
going to be a much bigger character
Carlos Valdez said that their
relationship is going to get a little
more serious maybe we'll see more of
Earth 19 we will see the accelerated man
come back but they haven't said anything
beyond them just bringing back fan
favorites you obviously saw peekaboo in
the trailer we found her from behind the
scenes that's all episode 1 most of this
99% of this footage is episode 1 stuff
but the funny thing at the end of the
trailer is that when you see the red
costume flash running in the subway from
behind is Cisco is on the airfield
saying I've got them I've got them as
han Solo would say I made a few
modifications myself it's actually two
completely different scenes so this is
Wally in the costume you just don't see
his face it's meant to be a surprise
this is from them trying to bring Barry
back they absolutely confirmed that the
season 4 villain is going to be the
thinker we've known that for a while we
knew about the mechanic they confirmed
that the mechanic will be a female
character is that they just wanted to
switch it up after doing speedster
villains for so many years so it will be
the fastest man alive
against the fast
mind alive which I think I actually
talked about in a video a little while
ago the other upside or consequence of
not having Barry around is that iris now
spends a lot more time with Kid Flash
and they get more of those
brother-sister moments like you saw
during flash point they had that
crime-fighting team it was just the two
of them so even though it's sort of this
crazy changed team flash so you can see
the effects of bringing her into STAR
Labs
so that she spends a lot more time
around him day to day helping out in the
way that she did during the flashpoint
timeline speaking of which you probably
saw my Justice League video they
confirmed that the flash movie with Ezra
Miller in the DC EU will be a flashpoint
movie so we just had to bring this meme
back what a nice timeline wouldn't it be
a shame if somebody messed it up going
all the way back to season 2 so just a
reminder that the show is coming back
the second week in October which is
around when it normally comes back we
also got our first look at Erica Durance
on Supergirl that was the Smallville
character that's coming into the arrow
verse so she is now part of the arrow
verse she's playing a version of Cara's
mother
so she goes from being married to a
Kryptonian to actually being a
Kryptonian in Tom Welling another big
Smallville name-drop he's actually going
on Lucifer season 3 even though I don't
make videos for that it's just funny to
see more the Smallville actors start
popping up again but as we learn more
about the flash I'll do more videos
there'll be a bunch more follow-up stuff
happening next week because I can't get
to the arrow Supergirl legends of
tomorrow trailers there's even stranger
things season 2 a lot of stuff that I
didn't have time for that I'll do next
week but up next tonight I'll be doing
videos for the Marvel trailers they drop
for Thor Ragnarok and anything else
we'll see if they drop infinity war but
while you wait for everything click here
for the Justice League trailer and you
can click here for all my other
comic-con videos thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight